womöglich ist das heute ein zumindest
heikler tag für den weltfrieden wir
wollen über die lage sprechen mir ist
zugeschaltet herrsche publizist und
chinaexperte austria ich grüße sie dahin
position ja wie ernster beurteilen sie
die lage es gibt die drohungen chinas
auch militärische konsequenzen folgen zu
lassen
der ernst dieser lage ist zuerst ein
politischer ernst es ist ja ein crash
von politischen programmen aufeinander
ein programm dass chinas
präsident in bingen und silikon parteien
verfolgen und sie können sehr wenig noch
von dem programm zurückweichen weil sie
mit dem rücken zur wand stehen weil sie
in eine wirtschaftskrise stecken weil
sie vor dem chinesischen volk ein recht
fertigungs note zu bewältigen hatten und
auf der anderen seite ist auch schon
seit jahren die chinesische isolation in
der welt deutlich geworden ist besondere
im bezug auf den festlichen welt nicht
nur die usa sondern es zunehmend auch
europa auch die usa und der westen hat
wenig spielraum wie es sich jetzt gerade
in dem krieg der in der ukraine gezeigt
hat zurückzuweichen schauen wir mal auf
taiwan die usa haben sich der
verteidigungsfähigkeit taiwans
verpflichtet was bedeutet das
das bedeutet zuerst das seit geraumer
zeit seit mehr als 30 jahren alle sorten
vom waschen nach treibern geliefert
werden von amerikanern bis auf die
langfristige
langstreckenraketen sind beinahe alle
machen mit dabei und das andere ist
quasi die schrittweise einbindung
treibern sind ein regionaler
verteidigungs netz insbesondere beginn
mit japan japan hat ein sicherheits für
bündnis mit den usa japan hat ein
zweites
kommandozentrale
auf den
grund die japanischen politische führung
sagt er klipp und klar dass dieses
zweite zentraler die ganze region
abdeckt und wenn dann von der ganzen
region die rede ist dann ist auch
teilweise mit timer ansprüche auch
wirtschaftlich eine wichtige rolle wie
abhängig ist die weltwirtschaft von
taiwan
im unterschied zur abhängigkeit von
china ist thailand er ein
high-tech-land wir klicken zum beispiel
diese schiffsindustrie die in taiwan
sehr stark ist ich glaube verschiedenen
zahlen gehen davon aus dass 60 bis 70
prozent aller chips aus taiwan kommen
von einem sehr großen firma die sehr
präzise
chips technologie beherrschen wenn
teilweisen jackson nicht mehr lieferte
sind auch alle sagen wir mal
automobil-hersteller
lahmgelegt das schließt auch deutschland
mit 1 das haben wir in den letzten
jahren der korona krise zu genüge
kennengelernt es werden jetzt öfter
parallelen auch zum russland ukraine
konflikt gesehen moskau hat sich heute
ganz eindeutig hinter peking gestellten
kreml sprecher sagte man sei absolut
solidarisch mit china
droht eine einnahme taiwans durch china
in der zeitlichen kürze sehe ich dieses
szenario noch nicht ich glaube vielmehr
dass china gerade an dem krieg russland
in der ukraine sehr genau studiert was
man nicht machen darf man traf sich zum
beispiel nicht überschätzen man darf
eine blitzaktion eine sogenannte
blitzkrieg nicht überschätzen
insbesondere dann in bezug auf thailand
denn die ukraine ist ein flaches land
von überall können die panzer von jetzt
auf gleich
einströmen taiwan ist aber eine insel
und beim insel kann man nicht einfach
mit panzern überrollt
da ist auch schon die militärische
risiko
szenario wesentlich komplexer wesentlich
gefährlicher ich glaube nicht dass teil
waren jetzt von tina sofort übernommen
werden kann
auch die chinesische führung spricht
nicht davon gerade jetzt am ersten
august das ist im grunde zeigt sich in
dieses schon armee in der rheder des
verteidigungsministeriums wurde
verteidigungsministers persönlich hat
man kein wort erwähnt zu einer
gewaltsamen befreiung von taiwan das
wäre dann eine normale sprachentwicklung
aber die ist einfach nicht da ist sie
herzlichen dank für diese einschätzung
an diesem heutigen tag